thank you everyone for joining my name's
nick heaton my lab is at duke university
and what i'm going to talk to you about
today
are some genetic approaches that we've
been taking to identify host factors we
think that can be targeted to prevent
influenza virus disease
so if the goal is to better control
influenza virus infection there are
really two ways that we can go about
this
the first is to target the virus
directly and the second is to target
something about the host cell
so the virus can no longer replicate
now in this first approach this is i
think probably
most more intuitive to most people this
is what we've done historically develop
small molecules that inhibit viral
enzymes or functionality of virus
proteins so the virus just really can't
replicate
tamiflu or also tamavir for example is a
small molecule that inhibits
the neuramidase protein of virus which
is required for the virus to leave cells
and go on to infect
neighboring cells
the second approach is targeting the
host cell and this is
interest has increased in kind of this
this second option
recently
and again the idea is to change
something about
the host response
essentially leaving the virus alone but
making the host less permissive for
infection
so again different ways one can go about
this the first is to try and enhance the
natural immune response to infection
we recognize that cells already have
ways to detect the virus and respond to
that virus and so one school of thought
is that we simply just
might find ways to help the immune
system just function a little better and
in this way better control virus
infection
the other approach is to directly
prevent viral infection or replication
the actual target cells where the virus
needs to replicate
and one can do this by eliminating a
necessary host factor so all viruses
require
co-opting proteins in the host cell to
complete their replication cycle so if
you can find a host protein that is
absolutely essential for the virus and
get rid of that now the virus can no
longer replicate or alternatively
cells can upregulate genes
that encode for proteins that
intrinsically restrict virus infection
going back to this kind of immune
activation idea a lot of these cytokines
that are made after a cell detects virus
infection talk to neighboring cells tell
them to turn on these genes
and if these genes are turned on before
it's exposed to a virus that cell is now
non-permissive for infection
and so at least at a high level
these various options are at least
theoretical approaches for waves
that influenza virus could be controlled
and we've been interested in the
host side of things what i'm going to
tell you about today are two kind of
shorter stories
that relate to enhancing the immune
response to infection or identifying
virus restriction factors and i'm going
to start with the restriction factor
story
so for any host directed therapeutic
the first thing you have to have is the
target what is the actual host protein
that you want to change expression of
and so to find those targets we and many
other groups have taken high throughput
genetic approaches to identify such
such factors and one approach that can
be used is crispr casting-based
technology
i think most people are more aware of
the technology in the context of
knocking out changes that diagrams here
on the left
and essentially how this works
is a catalytically active cas9 protein
can be targeted to a specific genomic
locus
by virtue of the sequence of the guide
rna
and when this is targeted to an exon
cas9 can make a cut
in the dna a double-stranded break which
the host cell then
fixes imperfectly
and frequently leads to frame shifts
and the knockout of that protein
and so you can do screens with this
technology and what that gives you
are the factors that are necessary for
viral replication when they're lost the
virus can no longer replicate
the slight permutation of that
technology
i'm showing here on the right this is
called dcas9 activation
which again is using cas9 protein but
now cast 9 is catalytically inactive can
no longer cut dna
the guide rna still targets it to a
locus but now it's targeting it to
promoters instead of the middle of the
gene
and finally and importantly cast 9 and
the rna
work in such a way that transcriptional
activators are are dragged to these
promoters and it actually turns on genes
it actually increases expression rather
than knocking them out
what you get when you use that kind of
technology are factors that are
sufficient for viral control
um
factors that all by themselves are able
to stop viral infection
and
the the two stories i'm going to tell
you about today are using that
technology
now we wanted to find
uh cellular factors that when they were
up regulated would make the cell
completely resistant to infection
so we decided to use a reporter system
which i've diagrammed here on the left
so instead of just taking
regular cells and infecting them with a
virus and seeing
you know what cells live and which cells
die
we integrated this transgenic cassette
which is
a promoter followed by a lock stop locks
cassette and then a green fluorescent
protein
and we use that particular reporter
because we have an influenza virus that
expresses creep recombinase and
prerecombinase is a protein that binds
those locks p sites and removes the
stock cassette so after viral infection
the cells turn green
and the reason that we use this system
was because that's a very sensitive way
to label any cell that's ever seen
infection very little
virally expressed creed has to be
expressed for these cells to turn green
so that gives us some different
potential outcomes of infected all the
infected cells turn green
if the cells get infected and die
they're gone we don't even see them
but for the cells that are still there
the ones that aren't infected or never
got infected even a little bit are not
green compared to those uh which may
have had an abortive infection or
something like this
this is a system we want to use we want
to identify these cells that didn't get
any infection and not green ones
and i have some data here showing you
that this system works this is flow
cytometry it's green fluorescence on the
x-axis if we infect
with an unmodified virus that doesn't
have cree there's no reporter expression
but if we infect with our pre-expression
virus you can see by 24 hours the cells
turn brightly
so that's the system that we use the
screen we actually did is shown here
so if these guide rnas that tell casino
where to go and what genes
to activate
so we use a huge library of these guide
rnas it has three specific sequences for
every or for open reading frame of the
human genome
and the screen is shown here at the
bottom are in the uh
underneath those those words we take a
bunch of cells
and we deliver the guide rnas in such a
way that each cell only gets one guy rna
so after that happens what you get are a
population of cells where every cell in
the dish is upregulating a different
gene
then we put on the virus
and basically let the virus kill any
cells that it can right if a gene is
being upregulated it doesn't matter with
respect to virus infection that cell
just dies and is eliminated from the
population
after the virus is done killing all the
cells it can we collect the remaining
cells and sort them right we sort out
the green ones from the not green ones
now
and then we sequence them we sequence
those guide rnas to see what was
enriched and we compare that to what was
there prior to putting virus on
when you do a screen we do it in
replicates and what i hope you can
appreciate these are graphs that are
showing um
basically the abundance of different
guide rnas and you can see that we
strongly enrich for a small subset of
these guide rnas
but what are these guide rnas targeting
so we can do
bioinformatic analysis and see which
genes are predicted to be up regulated
and in this
particular plot
the size
and the heights
of the dot corresponding to every gene
in the genome
shows how abundant they were in our
sequencing
so you can see along the x-axis here
that most of the genes are not important
at all there's a few genes which are a
little bit important
but then clearly in red here at the top
this gene b4 gallon 2 is by far the most
enriched in our screen
for those cells that became resistant to
the virus and were not green at all
this is the most abundant
guide rna
so the first thing we have to do is test
that right this is still just a
prediction
so the first thing we do is
do a western blot at least on my screen
the beta acting control is not it's not
displaying but you have to take my word
for it there's equal loading and you can
see that when we put in the guide rna
targeting b4 gamma 2 we actually see
up regulation of that gene
and then we can go ahead and infect
these cells we made two different cell
lines which are over expressing v4
gallon 2 compared to a control you can
see that a control here we're just
inspecting with a gfp express virus so
that's a direct measurement of infection
the control cells get infected while the
b4 gala 2 overexpressing cells
are able to prevent that virus infection
so it looks like this is a good hit this
looks like
it's a real restriction factor of the
virus
so what is b4 gallon 2 and what does it
do with a glycol transferase which
basically adds sugars
to a glycant so for those of you that
aren't glycobiologists i made you a
cartoon here so glycans are basically
chains of sugars that are added to the
top of glycoproteins
throughout as they go through the
secretory pathway
so this glycan here like where it ends
on the bottom that little black line
that's where it would be attached to the
protein which would then be attached to
the cell
and these sugars
the the overall glycan can be composed
of different sugars which i gave you a
little key on the bottom of the slide
there
so with respect to flu infection the
sugar that's really important is this
little purple diamond on the top that's
the viral receptor that's the cyalic
acid moiety
and what b4 gallant 2 is known to do
is this
it takes stylic acid containing glycans
and it adds a galmax to the subterminal
galactose so that now this cyalic acid
has a neighbor
but the cyalic acid is still there
so why wouldn't the virus be able to use
this as a receptor that that became our
next question
[Music]
it's possible our first thought was that
it was possible that this isn't a gene
that's normally expressed in lung cells
and we're expressing it to a high level
so maybe under those conditions it just
does something different than we would
expect it to do
so we can see if that's the case um
by collecting the glycans from the
surface of cells doing hplc and
performing mass spec which i'm showing
you a representation of that data here
so on the top is the um
that can are glycans from control cells
this is normal and i know it's small but
hopefully you can make out that
these glycans look basically like the
cartoon that i showed you in the
previous slide these little cyalic acids
are all out there on the surface
when we do the same analysis for v4
gallon 2 expressing cells
again just what we expect there's these
little neighbors
these gal max next to the science acid
but we don't see any modifications that
are anything different so it looks like
it's the normal
modification of b4 gallon two
that somehow even though the cyanic acid
is there the receptor is still there we
can't find it
so we decided to
study a little bit look a little bit
closer
at why proteins could recognize static
acids proteins that normally bind stylic
acids
now cannot do so
so the viral hemoglutinin that's the
receptor binding protein by insalic
acids
but there's lots of proteins that bind
sugars they're they're broadly called
lectins
and wheat germa gluten which is
abbreviated here wga is one that broadly
binds stylic acids so we use this um
protein it's fluorescently labeled so
green signal is where it's binding
you can see that they control cells on
the left
they're all bound by wheat german
glutinone and on the right that binding
goes way down so it seems like it's not
a flu specific thing proteins in general
that recognize phylic acid
have a hard time doing so after before
gallon 2 has added this extra sugar
but sciatic acids can be attached
to the subterminal galactose via
different chemistries one is called an
alpha-2 3-link stylic acid
linkage and one's called an alpha-2 6
linkage
so we decided to look a little more in
depth if there was any differences um
you know kind of in lessons with
different specificities
so what i'm showing you are histograms
from flow cytometry analysis and the
first one i'm showing is wheat germ
agglutinin which i showed you the
microscopy pictures right above you can
see that when we have b4 gallon 2 over
expressing which is in the green we get
less binding
now when we use lectins that are
specific for stylic acids with different
linkages
for example the 2 3 linkage
you can see that that is significantly
decreased as well
but interestingly when we look at the 2
6 linkage
uh
with with preference for the 2 6 linked
stylic acids we don't see any difference
and this is potentially a problem if
we're talking about restriction of
influenza viruses
because different strains of influenza
viruses
use silac acids that are linked to that
subterminal galactose in different ways
so influenza viruses have a large host
range
they infect birds which i'm going to
talk about here in humans
and the bird strains prefer this alpha 2
3-link cyalic acid as a receptor while
the human strains prefer alpha-2
6-linked
phallic acids as we're sent
so our mass spec before didn't
distinguish
between which of these
which of these glycans with different
linkages between that galactose and
stylic acid would be modified by b4
gallon 2.
but we can do exactly that analysis
called a glycan linkage analysis
and our lectins would predict we only
affect the two three containing
glycans the third glycans
when we do the analysis that's exactly
what we see two six-linked phylic acids
are not modified only two threes
this actually makes sense if we go back
and we think about the virus we used for
the screen we use a laboratory adapted
h1n1 virus
called pr8
which was initially isolated from people
or from a person but has been passaged
in chicken eggs since the 1930s and has
acquired a preference for this
particular linkage
so these data all suggest that we would
strongly restrict avian viruses but not
human strains of viruses
and so we decided to test that
what i'm showing here is a crystal
violet staining assay
we're basically putting on virus at
different dilutions
and if the cells are killed they float
away and crystal violet won't stain so
if the cells have been killed
you have these clear wells well the
cells are still there you have these
dark
black and white but they would be purple
wells
so in mock infected on the top left
there's no virus all the cells are there
when we infect with an h7n2 avian virus
you can see we kill the control cells
much more than the b4 gallon 2 over
expressing cells that trend holds true
for h9n2 viruses or h5n9 viruses or h10
and iv
basically any avian virus
that we put on b4 gallon 2 expressing
cells they're strongly restricted
um
which you know again makes sense i'm not
going to show you the data but when we
repeat this analysis with human viruses
the ones that like the alpha 2 3 link
stylic acid we don't see any significant
inhibition
so we're only part of the way there
avian viruses cause severe disease in
people when they're exposed
highly pathogenic avian influenza
viruses
so now b4 gallon two is potentially a
host factor that we could target
to restrict those viruses
but we really want to find host targets
that would block infection in a strained
independent manner something that would
get all strains of it
so what is a kind of
can viral
process that we could potentially target
and here we returned back to this idea
of the immune system
because the immune system restricts
influenza viruses similarly irrespective
of their
receptor usage and in particular i'm
going to highlight the interferon
response
type one interferon is one of these
inflammatory cytokines that is made when
an infected cell detects that infection
it initiates what's called jack stat
signaling and turns on interferon
stimulated genes or isgs
and these pro have antiviral activity
so that anti-viral activity is what
restricts the virus but in addition to
that
uh interferon also turns on negative
regulators of this
signaling which limits ultimately um the
kind of magnitude of the antiviral
activity
so if this is the model if type one
interferon induces both negative
regulators and the interferon stimulated
genes that have antiviral activity those
negative negative regulators restrict
these isgs maybe
if we figure out what these negative
regulators are and remove them
we could induce interferon stimulated
genes to a higher level have higher
antiviral activity and basically help
the immune system function a little
better with respect to controlling these
viruses
again the question is what should we be
targeting
so we need a readout for interferon
response
we made
the construct which is shown here i'm
not going to go into the details other
than to say in the promoter we have
these interferon sensitive response
elements or isres
and this is what this is where
transcription factors bind after they
are
induced by interferon signaling
and then we induce a variant of gfp that
makes the cells turn green
and it works if we add interferon the
cells turn bright green
so we want to find negative regulators
and the screen we did
to find them is diagrams here again we
take a large number of cells
we introduce the guide rnas so we're
turning on one gene in every cell
we collect some of them to know where we
started from
we treat the rest of the cells with
interferon and the vast majority of them
turn green
we collect them for
sorting
but what we're collecting is not the
green ones we're collecting the ones
that aren't green cells that have
upregulated a negative regulator of
interferon so strongly that the cell now
fails to respond to interfere
we take those gfp negative cells and
sequence the guide rnas that are in them
compared to what we started with
and after bioinformatics bioinformatic
analysis and a bunch of
filters that i won't go into today for
the sake of time we got to three hits c1
vault one etv 7
153 then when overexpressed by
themselves are sufficient
to decrease that interferon response at
least that's read out by that reporter
um at least etv7 and enough 153
don't affect gfp by itself it's specific
for the interferon response and we
decide to focus
on atv7
it's known to be an interferon
stimulated gene
and it's a dna binding transcription
factor but it had no known role in the
regulation of interferon signaling
so we decided to study that further
again our validation to this point has
been limited to our reporter which is
still an artificial system
so does it affect the real interferon
response and suppress real isgs
this is um
a qpcr assay for rna levels so we're
adding interferon and the control cells
we're getting interferon stimulated
genes here i'm just showing you two
representative ones when atv7 is being
overexpressed you can see the magnitude
of that response is significantly
decreased
uh you can make that out of the protein
level here on the right when etv7 is
there
and the presence of interferon
interferon stimulated genes are
upregulated to a much smaller extent
the reciprocal is also true if we knock
out this negative regulator now the rna
levels for representative isgs go up
more than control
and the protein level shows the same
trend in the knockout cells you get more
isgs that then control cells
so how is it working i told you these
isrs are the sites in dna that
basically allow the specific interferon
induced transcription factors to turn on
gene expression
etv7 is a transcription factor we know
the sequence that it likes to bind in in
terms of dna
and that i'm showing you here on the
bottom ggaa is the central motif that
etb7 uses to bind to its sites
so if you look at the consensus sequence
of isres there's two spots that could be
etv7 binding sites
depending on what that n is
so if we look at the promoters of real
isgs
and say do we ever get a ggaa
here are some example isgs on the right
and you can see in most of their
promoters
they do indeed have a gga
in their kind of their canonical isr
but not all
which led us to this idea that while
edv7 may be a repressor of interferon
stimulated genes it will probably affect
different isgs to a different extent
based on the specific sequence in their
promoters
so to test that we did rna sequencing
i'm showing you a heat map on the right
m cherry is the control etv7 is the
negative regulator if we add interferon
you can see that the control cell genes
the expression of isgs all goes up
orange is up in this case an etv7
broadly restricts that but if you look
towards the bottom of the heat map
there are some isgs that are only
modestly effective
affected compared to at the top the ones
that are strongly affected so it does
seem like it has differential responses
we learned a little more about its
action if we go back to our reporter the
initial construct that we have the isres
all have etv7 binding sites this ggaa
which probably explains why we pulled it
out in our screen but we can modify that
so that those types are all still isrs
but don't have etv7 binding sites
and when we do that compared to the
the interferon reporter that we started
with which is on the left side of that
graph or etb7 is mediating effect
the non
etv7 binding site version of it still
responds to interferon but now etv7 has
no effect
to show that it's directly binding that
sequence we did an oligo-based ip where
essentially we took a biotinylated oligo
which either has
an isre with an ecb7 binding site here
this is an israel for my isg-15
or a mutant where we've changed one
position so it's no longer
a
etv7 consensus binding site
when we take these oligos and go fishing
and cell life states you can see that we
pull down etv7 with the wild type of
nothing using isr
so to basically sum up this part quickly
we think that ecb 7 works
by competitively binding these israe
sites and preventing the normal
activating transcription factors from
binding that's how it suppresses the
interference
but again back to our goal
we were trying to find negative
regulators that we could remove to
increase activity against influenza
viruses and if you look at this list on
the right
of genes that are affected by db7 a lot
of them have activity against influenza
viruses
so if we go back to our model now kind
of generic negative regulator's been
replaced with etv7 it's blocking these
isgs that have anti-viral activity if we
get rid of it we should get more isgs
better control of virus
and that's indeed what we see here we're
taking a virus we're doing a multi-cycle
growth curve the virus grows much more
poorly on the knockout cells compared to
the control because these knockout cells
are detecting the virus and responding
better than the control cells which are
being
which are having their interference
response suppressed by atv set
this is what it actually looks like
in terms of kind of green signal we're
infecting with the green virus the
control cell the virus is spreading
across the plate you're getting green
signal compared to the knockout cells
where these cells are now responding
particularly well to infection
and it doesn't just happen with this
strain other strains of influenza a
like california o9 or influenza b virus
malaysia o4 they're both restricted
so it seems that we've accomplished our
goal here finding a host factor
that can broadly restrict influenza
viruses
now some of you
may be thinking
what i'm about to say now and
what i want to leave you with is kind of
this idea of how how can we potentially
use one of these host factors
clinically if we were modulating etv7
this is something that we want to do and
again the question here is severe
influenza disease
people who die from flu
it's associated with hyperinflammation
so would we really want to suppress a
negative regulator
of inflammation to control the virus
and i think the answer is probably not
in all cases but we can envision some
cases where we think it would be helpful
for example
as a prophylactic treatment for people
at high risk or people that are exposed
right here i've diagrammed five people
one has the virus you probably wouldn't
want to treat that person but for people
that are in close contact
suppressing etv7 such that their initial
response to the virus right away
as soon as they're exposed works better
you could potentially head off virus
infection not not let it establish
um you know severe disease in the first
place we could see a modulator working
in that context
additionally there are some people which
are infected with the virus that
clinically it's been decided they
actually should be treated with
interferon that the interferon response
would be helpful and obviously in that
case potentiating that therapy by
suppressing interference or suppressing
etv7 so that interferon works better
it's potentially a useful
approach for
uh you know for an etv7 targeting
therapy
okay so to wrap up
non-traditional antiviral proteins such
as b4 gala 2 can be identified with high
throughput screening the beginning i
have talked to you about this protein
that modifies the host receptor that
prevents virus binding
although the stylic acid isn't directly
modified
however because it's specific for only
some of these glycans it's a strong
restrictor of avian influenza viruses
but not human influenza viruses
we also identify a host immune response
modulator
that helps restrict the spread of
influenza viruses
uh it limits all strains that we've
tested
and
an important point i think to highlight
is that in addition to influenza viruses
other pathogens aren't controlled by
type 1 interferon and so this type of
targeting may have brought efficacy
and our current and future work really i
mean we're continuing to identify most
more host targets but that only gets you
part of the way there right we need ways
to safely and transiently upregulate and
down regulate these factors to actually
um
you know move them into the clinic and
actually treat people with them
the last slide i'll show you is the most
important slide the people who actually
did the work the etv7 work was primarily
done by heather with some help from ryan
the
b4 gallant 2 work was done primarily by
brooke with some help from al we have
some great collaborators inside and
outside of duke and we're funded
[Music]
you know by these various sources we're
we're very lucky to have this funding to
be able to do this type of work
i will wrap up now
if there are any questions please feel
free to contact me
thank you for your attention